without further ado we are in the
studios of rush limbaugh
uh first i want to congratulate you 30
years
talk radio the king of talk radio and
going
stronger than ever it's amazing it
really is you know i'm enjoying it as
much as i ever have
if not more so i get more thrills from
it i get more satisfaction from it than
i've ever had
if you would have told me 30 years ago
or even 40 when i was dreaming of all
this that by the time i reached 65
that it would be more competitive than
ever that i would be more involved
i thought 65 way you got left to prove
you phoned it in you take it easy go to
the beach
do a couple hours a week and that's it
like johnny carson i
i can't imagine not doing this and i
think largely because of you
as you just laid out we are seriously at
a tipping point i don't know
i worry i don't know how many people
actually are aware
of how close we are to losing
our country as founded there's always
going to be an america but what is it
going to be
and it really is at stake and i've been
trying in
i don't know how many ways to explain to
my audience
why it's different now than it was 15
years ago or 20
and i do it by trying to analyze who the
left
is what they have become uh
i'm naive in many ways uh and i i i
might take a little objection to
rush b and naive you tell me if this is
naive i i look at what happened during
the kavanaugh hearing
you just described ricin and stuff to
susan collins
we looked at the literal mob
behavior that was inspired bought and
paid for
by the democrat party the media
encourages it
in my naive world that behavior
would secure the biggest landslide
defeat
a political party has ever had in a sane
world
where decent people are the majority
that would be rejected
out of hand it wouldn't even be
considered relevant
and the people this country would want
to get rid of that as
quickly as they could but yet it may be
close to 50 percent of the country i
don't think it is and i hope not
but the fact that it continues to
survive i've i've evolved a bunch of
theories to explain it
and i really think uh by the way
interrupt any time with a question i
don't know
you're doing great i really think
that all of this or the vast majority of
it still
sean revolves around one of the age-old
arguments that left versus writer's head
and that is role
of government in our lives now the
people on the left i read some of
jim garrity at national review about a
month ago now and it just
struck me because i think it's dead on
i'm going to paraphrase what he said
he said what has happened in his vienna
and i endorse this i think even more
than heath i think it's a bigger point
than he made it
these people on the left that you've
described the mob behavior
is really a series of psychological
disorders
that have taken over politics we have
politicized
psychological disorders to the point now
that they have become
the objective of the democrat party
solving all of these
disparate separate psychological
disorders having the government do it
basically determine outcomes
and get even with oppressors the
founding majority of the country that's
what we're dealing with
and we if we don't define this properly
we're never going to be able to oppose
it
if we consider this stuff legit which it
isn't that kind of behavior is not
legitimate
we don't want a country based on that
kind of we don't want people
winning elections based on mobs and
violence we don't want
to think if that happens if they win the
election based on this kind of behavior
get more of it
exactly right but here's what we got
what did decent people do
what did decent people do not spend all
day trying to figure out how to how to
battle this decent people
are living their lives we've got we've
got perversion
indecency corruption up against what
used to be called
normalcy you got hillary clinton so
we can't have we can't be civil unless
you give us power back
eric holder well they go low we kick
them right
maxine waters uh if you see them
create a crowd you know tell go
tell them follow them into department
stores and grocery stores and gas
stations
you're not wanted anywhere anymore
and we saw pam bondi and secretary
nielsen
and we saw sarah sanders ted cruz and
his wife heidi
mitch mcconnell i think rand is right
somebody's gonna get hurt here in the
end because
we look i blame the people for their
actions
but there's certainly marching orders
here confront
attack get in their faces all of it is
marching orders yeah
all of it is bought and paid for look at
this caravan
suppose that where's the honduras
guatemala wherever it's coming doesn't
matter
somebody's paying for this where are
these people going to the bathroom
who's feeding them i mean you look at
two thousand four
thousand people kids and that's the
magic they put
the children in there and we must accept
them we can't turn them away what's so
horrible
trump is separating it's all designed
and it's all designed to flood the zone
during the election we've got this
we've got worried about the fed raising
interest rates to try to jam down the
economy
and way over there guess what just
happened robert mueller is letting it
know that he's about ready to submit his
report
well justice department rules and
guidelines say that they should not do
anything to impact
the results of an election but that
didn't
comey did didn't he he was doing
everything he could to help hillary
people don't understand this but that's
what he was doing they had to have him
so these things are all planned and
they're all getting
focused leading up to the election
people ask me what
rush what can i do i want to do more
than vote right now that is the answer
right i mean people i know people think
their vote's not enough
but it is turnout turnout is everything
and the left
this is almost an identical scenario to
2016.
they think sean they really do
and some of this is hope but they think
a lot of americans who vote for trump
regret it
a lot of people can't wait to get out
there and show and apologize for their
mistake of voting for trump
they can't wait to go out there and
apologize to democrat party the fact of
the matter is
since barack obama the democrat party
has been losing elections
starting in 2010 midterms tea party all
the way up to 2016 the democrat party
has lost 1200 seats
national state local if you count all
the way down to dog catcher they've lost
they've had the they have the least
amount of electoral political power in
washington since the 20s
where is this blue wave where's the
evidence that people can't wait to vote
democrat the evidence
is that they're doing the exact opposite
trump is out there continuing to do the
things he did that won him the election
2016 all of these rallies
and and they have been unable to get rid
of they've thrown everything
at trump that usually gets rid of
republican opponents and nothing has
worked
and they're just frustrated as they can
be and i think they're so
overplaying this and they're going way
beyond the bounds of anywhere near
propriety but they think most americans
want to be encouraged to do mob like
behavior get in people's faces i don't
think we've lost the country to the
extent
that that wins elections how big an
impact kavanaugh
because we're talking kavanaugh was to
me was a tipping point
because they were exposed it didn't look
i think most people fundamentally
believe in the rule of law the
constitution
due process presumption of innocence
there was none of
that it was right accusation i believe
it yeah let me tell you how close they
were to getting away with that though
yeah i mean you and i watch this from a
different perspective and i think a lot
of people
sadly there are still a lot of people
that only get their newest and what we
call a mainstream media
if donald trump president trump had not
at that rally exposed
christine knows the robbery none the
four people she says were there
no we weren't she didn't know what where
when why so trump tells people this
and they get mad at trump for mocking
her trump didn't mock her to mock her
you'd have to impersonate her
um which i can do but i will not here
you're showing great restraint
he didn't mock her he exposed her to a
bunch of americans who didn't know
because the mainstream media had not
reported all of the halls in her story
so trump does and then in getting trump
they end up reporting what trump said
that
was the tipping point plus what
kavanaugh did to save himself but you're
right
presumption of innocence gone they were
close to killing that
by intimidating republicans on that
committee but it didn't work again
because i believe the president came in
and saved the day let's
look i don't have a crystal ball i
always
thought and believed in my heart the
media is wrong
trump could win you you could see it you
could feel it
i i don't know who was going to run
against uh obama and oh wait
you saw the crowds you saw the
enthusiasm
in that case i think it was a lot of
hype and no change
typical left-wing policies you predicted
to me
it would fail and it did fail but
something is different
president trump you could see a building
momentum
and now we've got these midterms i'm
looking at
let's florida they could pick up a
senate seat i think you could pick one
up
in missouri i think you'll hold nevada i
think you win in
in arizona uh north dakota
indiana all potential pickups where i
would worry about more is the house
i don't have a feel well
but let's look at this in the um
in the macro way let's let's compare
this you want to go back 2008 let's go
back to 2016.
i think i know you were early on
very confident trump was going to win i
thought my staff here will tell you
that two days when i first saw the first
polling after trump and melania
down the escalator i said he's the
nominee going to happen i felt it
you know why because i know the bond i
saw those rallies
i saw the bond that trump had with his
voters
the media didn't create that he did you
know i
i did versions of that when my show
started traveling around
48 weekends a year for the first two
years trying to get my radio show
established
and i that i i saw a similar success
track
and nobody can blow up that bond that
trump voters have
the washington establishment to this day
does not understand
donald trump they don't understand his
voters and they're not curious to find
out why
they just resent it and they are still
operating under the same rules they
operate under 2016
and the parallels are identical here
they think in 2016 hillary is going to
win
massive landslide they're measuring the
curtains hillary's planning all these
things
the deep state guys back then are
confident nobody's going to ever know
what they did
their jobs and their careers are going
to be safe struck strokes merc and all
these clowns mccabe
safe then trump comes along and wins
they're shocked they're stunned they
couldn't believe it
same thing now they think they've won
the house a month ago
it's in the can they're just waiting for
the calendar and the days to go by
when all of their own polling data shows
this so-called generic ballot blue wave
shrinking and traumatically
now you find less confidence um
in all of the reporting about the blue
wave uh
so now we've got the caravan they tried
capital look at all these october
surprises feinstein tried one
pocahontas elizabeth warren how about
this folks
we used to be judged by the content of
our character now it's the content of
our dna
is that what the democrat party how
about bastardizing martin luther king
she bombs out uh feinstein bombs out
right
uh and and so all these these all four
were
attempted that were purposed to blow
trump up
and he just keeps beating them back and
they don't know how to deal with it they
get more and more frustrated more and
more angry
and that's what we're seeing some nights
at the end of the show we'll take
a a clip from your dittocam and run it
kind of the kicker to the show people
love my audience love to see you
and thanks for doing the show they love
having you um as do i
what if they win what if the democrats
win
that's the most i i i love that question
well i the problem here is i'm on
television and i'm i'm really trying to
be persuasive and i don't want to
dramatize it and i don't want to
lie to people and i don't want to fill
people with
uh phony manipulative
emotional things but it it might serve
to answer that question to go back and
what if hillary had won
in 2016 stop and think of that
there wouldn't be a roaring economy
there wouldn't have been any tax cuts
there wouldn't have been any rollback of
regulations there wouldn't have been any
squaring of the deal with nato there
wouldn't have been any redone trade
deals
the obama administration told american
people get used to it there's a new
american economy in its flatline or in
decline america's past we didn't really
deserve that
america was founded by a white
patriarchy set itself up for
itself people discriminated against but
those days are over so now
the days behind us uh they we didn't
deserve those
anyway we don't deserve to be a
superpower so we had a flatline economy
we were told obama's out there in
indiana telling these people their jobs
are never
coming back and somebody in the audience
mr trump says he can bring him obama
says
what's he going to do wave a magic wand
look what happened we got the jobs back
it can be done
they don't even want to make america
great they resent the whole idea of
america becoming great they resent the
idea of america
as a superpower running the world for
good we're the good guys that i don't
think so
if but the investigation well but we'll
get if he hadn't
won sean
i shudder to think with hillary clinton
in the white house and all of her
cronies in all the cabinet positions
uh and the validation of all of these
oddball weird perverted
left-wing behaviors becoming more and
more normalized
and politics and government's role being
to address their grievances and we've
become a country
of nothing but a bunch of victims
constantly angry demanding that somebody
do something about it
instead of all of us as we used to do
using self-reliance
and our own initiative in our guts and
handling life
ourselves